For three.
Whoops,
we've got an issue.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Five,
four,
three,
two.
Yes.
And we're loud.
Hello Lindsey.
What's happening?
Not much.
Thanks.
Pleasure to meet you.
Yeah,
yeah.
Good to meet you.
I'm,
I'm the girl who tags you in all the disgusting medical history photos and I'm
really looking forward to gross you out.
Your audience
can forward to you doing that as well.
You have a fascinated me with your Twitter page and you like,
first of all,
how you are a doctor,
right?
Well,
I'm a phd.
I can't save anybody's life.
Perform,
you know,
Victorian surgery,
amputation or something like anybody can write.
Yeah,
yeah.
Is that a real one?
This is,
this is a prop.
Um,
so this is,
this was a,
was a real fun thing to get through customs when I was coming in from Britain.
It's a of Victorian amputation saw.
It's called the clockwork saw.
And,
um,
for people who are just listening,
it's a,
it's a circular saw and there would have been a crank that you wound it with and
then you'd release it and it would spin sort of automatically.
Oh God.
Yeah.
And the idea was that it would make it faster.
But the reason why I love this sauce so much is that it was a massive failure.
And,
um,
I don't think we talk about failure enough in science and medicine.
You know,
all the things that work,
there's a lot of things that don't work.
And so this guy who invented this saw when he tried it out,
it was spinning so fast that he took off his assistance fingers.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Oops.
I'm,
it never got out of prototype phase.
So I had to recreate it for my youtube channel.
Now when you were in those old days when they didn't have antibiotics and
antiseptic and,
right,
yeah.
When they saw someone's leg off or something like that,
how many times those people live?
Well,
you could pull through the operation.
That was one part of it.
But then of course you could die postoperative infection.
So my book,
uh,
the Patreon are really focuses on this one guy named Joseph Lister,
who applies germ theory and develops antisepsis.
So germ fighting techniques,
right.
And most people don't know who he is,
but they know the product.
Listerine.
So with stream was named after him by,
I always tell people that.
So basically a lister was a British surgeon and he came to America in 1876 to
convince the medical community of germs.
And there was a guy in the audience and he decided to create this product.
Listerine.
But it wasn't even a mouthwash in the 19th century.
It was used to treat gonorrhea.
Whoa.
So,
but also I don't endorse that little blistery and go to a doctor,
man.
Yeah.
I could just see all the comments already on the youtube,
you know,
she told me to throw with starry night.
No,
I,
I don't endorse that.
And I'm sure the Listerine company is not too pleased at talking about that
either.
So Listerine now just is for breath,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
It's all it does.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a,
it's an antiseptic mouthwash.
And so even in the good for you,
like is it good to kill all that stuff inside your mouth?
Like I'm not a real doctor,
but you're a medical historian and a medical historian.
I would say that Dennis would say that that was stirring still a good product
area.
Yeah.
Form of it.
Something like that.
I just use something,
I don't know if it's crap.
The mouthwash.
You got to switch to Listerine now.
Honor of,
of Joseph Lister.
So how did he know?
How did he know that there was germs?
That they were real?
So let me,
let me take you back to sort of before he walks on the scene.
So these operating theaters,
they were filled to the rafters with ticketed spectators.
People actually bought tickets to see someone get their leg hacked off.
Oh No.
How much does it cost?
You know what?
No one's asked me that.
I don't know how much to take.
It would cost for that,
that spectacle.
Now I really need to look into that.
Um,
but people would pay to watch that they paid for the book.
What they pay to watch now.
Right.
You know,
we could say,
you know,
and when I sent you my book,
I signed it and I said,
I thought that being strapped to the Victorian operating theater was the
original fear factor because I can't imagine anything worse than being strapped
to this table.
And so we're talking about before anesthesia,
so you're fully awake.
Um,
and one of my favorite surgeons is this guy named Robert Liston.
He's six two,
he's really tall for the 19th century.
And he could hold you down with his left arm and you could take your leg off in
about 30 seconds,
which is what you'd want if that's what you'd want.
But that's still a long time.
It is.
Yeah.
I mean,
if we just sat here for 30 seconds with dead airtime and you could think about
hacking through that light,
and
I wonder how many people would be at the end of this podcast?
Like five people would be still out there listening.
Um,
so,
so he was incredibly fast.
He was known as the fastest knife in the west end.
He would walk in,
he was a showman.
So we'd walk in and he'd say,
Timey gentlemen.
And you could just hear the ripple of pocket watches as they came out.
There he is.
Yup.
Yeah.
So actually the list and knife that he invented was this long bladed knife,
which they think jack the ripper may have also used on,
which is why those rumors are that Jack the ripper may have been a medical
practitioner,
but a really common thought.
Yeah.
I mean,
we're never going to know who he is.
It's unknowable.
We're still kind of obsessed with this.
I've heard so many different versions.
Yeah.
And recently there was some kind of bogus DNA test of,
of a shawl that they side belonged to one of the victims,
but it's impossible to prove the provenance of the object.
But that was,
that was listing.
So he's 62,
he's really tall.
Um,
one of my favorite stories is he would go so fast as he was a switching
instruments,
he'd hold these bloody instruments in his mouth just to illustrate how different
this was.
That's the face I wanted.
I wanted you to speak just totally through this whole segment.
Um,
and as he was switching instruments,
he accidentally caught cutoff is assistance finger.
And then as he was switching instrument,
he slashed the code of a spectator and the assistant died of gangrene.
The patient died of gangrene and the spectator died of fright.
So it's just right.
He died a,
the bright blood.
Wow.
He got slashed in the,
with the jacket and I guess he had a heart attack from the stress.
And so it's jokingly referred to as the only operation with a 300% mortality
rate.
Did a good job that day.
He killed three,
three people in one.
And you say slashed,
you mean he cut the spectator or just,
no,
he just cut their coat as he was kind of switching instruments and all that took
to kill someone.
I thought people were tougher back then.
Well,
not that guy now.
He lives forever in the butchery in art is that guy had a heart attack.
He must've had a heart attack.
It said he died of fright.
Maybe that wasn't real.
Maybe it was a course shit,
doesn't it?
A little bit.
No,
no,
no.
Of course.
These stories,
you know,
they get,
they get blown out portion.
Yeah.
It just seems like,
did you cut someone's jacket?
I'm going to die.
Well,
it's,
you know,
it's a stressful situation.
People are getting their limbs to hacked off.
You know,
your blood pressure would be really high.
Um,
and the,
and these theaters were,
I mean the,
the floor of the operating theater was crowded as well,
so they'd have to actually clear the forest sometimes.
So you can imagine,
you know,
you're strapped to this and the leg wasn't the worst thing.
So one of the tweets that you shared of mine,
which,
uh,
your platforms seem to enjoy quite a lot and sold me a lot of books,
by the way,
I think you,
I'm awesome.
Was this story about this guy who was suffering from a bladder stone and it got
stuck in his urethra.
And so out of desperation he stuck a nail down his penis and he hammered it to
break it up.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah,
people went nuts on your platform for that story.
So they,
they obviously are ready for this interview.
How did that work again,
that didn't work right?
It did not work.
Now he died.
Yeah.
Whoops.
That guy definitely died,
but it's,
it really illustrates how desperate people were back then and how few options.
Yeah,
they had,
or there's the image of it.
I don't think you'll have to show this tube,
Jamie,
who get back medical.
Yeah,
I'm sure it is medical.
I don't think you could try that on youtube.
Really?
That's clearly a penis.
There's penises and breasts on each mot of penis photos think they look at us
more careful.
All right,
well it's not on there.
I'm just,
okay,
good
for people.
People want to see it.
We'll tweet.
Twitter is the most open of all platforms.
I'll let you get away with almost every that you can have porn on Twitter.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
I don't have any problems with Instagram.
I put that stuff up,
but yeah,
but maybe things get removed from Instagram.
It's really kind of interesting.
It seems to be dependent upon how many people complain.
Yeah,
probably there's,
there's always those people out there looking to be offended.
I just think they just want to do something,
they just to press that,
right?
Yeah.
Oh,
I'm mad.
[inaudible] there we go.
Yeah,
I know.
I get,
uh,
you know,
at this point there's so many objects that that can cause a fence of course with
medical history and it's,
it's,
you know,
there's a lot of dark history Bodysnatchers and things like that.
And I'm a firm believer that we should tell these stories openly because they
happened in medicine and science grew as a result of it.
But,
but they're not easy subjects to discuss with an audience,
especially when you have so many characters in Twitter and you're,
you're trying to get out of complex idea.
Right,
right.
And also like,
you're not just,
gee,
there's a lot of Twitter pages that are fall where people just trying to gross
people out.
You're actually educating people about the history and we,
and we all should be really thankful that these people went through all this
stuff so that we don't have to.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I always say to my audience,
so I,
I've been going around the world sort of demolishing romantic notions about
people white,
it might think about what it's like to live in the past because it was pretty,
pretty bad.
And,
um,
I have visuals as well and um,
I've had four men faints so far.
It's always been,
man,
it's just a commentary right now.
It's always been men,
ancestors of the bitch.
Yeah,
exactly.
Cut.
It was bad guy.
Yeah.
Those,
those weekly is coming to my lecture.
And I think what it is though is people think I'm going to see something gross
so I'm not going to eat.
And then their blood sugar plummets.
So it's not really the,
by it.
They're not really prepared,
you know?
And there's an interesting,
yeah.
And they're standing sometimes I'm,
I,
I give lectures at this incredible museum called the old operating theater in
London.
It's the second oldest in the world.
And so you have to stand because it's like a Victorian operating theater.
And so people lock their knees or whatever.
Oh,
wow.
So you give actual lectures in the real theaters where they used to.
Yeah.
I did my book launch there and um,
if people want to see it,
um,
I filmed sort of a,
like a theatrical scene of a young lister attending an operation in that feeder
and it's on my youtube channel,
conduct under the knife.
And I really want to get this made into a movie.
Um,
I'm trying to come into Hollywood and convince Hollywood that this Quaker
searching from the Victorian period deserves the cinema a feature.
But it is an epic story.
He saved more lives than any other person to ever live.
We'll look at it is an epic story.
And for anybody who's ever gone through operations,
and I've gone through several of them,
we owe those people a massive,
yeah.
You don't have to be awake strapped to the table.
Both of my knees reconstructed.
Yeah.
Wake up and they're fixed.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
And,
and in the past,
before anesthesia,
a lot of times patients were sat in chairs so they weren't laid down.
Um,
and they were sat in these very high chairs so that their feet dangled so they
couldn't brace against the knife.
If you think about like pushing off with your feet,
of course.
Um,
there's a,
there's a story about a guy named Robert Penman and I know we have images and
I'm sure youtube won't take those down.
Um,
he,
he comes to Robert Liston,
the fastest knife in the west end and the eight and 18,
28 and he has this huge facial tumor growing.
I,
it's been growing for about eight years.
It's taking up his whole face.
He can't breathe now and list and looks at them and says,
I can't do this operation,
which is tantamount to a death sentence.
But he goes up to Scotland and he goes,
there he is.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's,
it's incredible when you see that painting.
Um,
so penman goes up to Scotland and he sees a guy named James Simon sime agrees to
do this operation and permanent sat for 24 minutes in a chair restrained while
this thing is cut out of his face,
drops in a bucket.
And,
and,
um,
yeah,
well we have a picture of them later in life,
you know,
and he looks,
it looks kind of like an ugly Abraham Lincoln and Lincoln wasn't really known
for his looks.
He doesn't have the thing on his face though.
Yeah.
I mean you could see that the jaw is definitely slimmer.
Um,
but he doesn't look too to form considering what he went through.
So it is incredible.
Um,
you get such crazy stories,
like there's a woman who has a mastectomy in 1840 without any anesthetic.
Now at this time,
you would have,
if you were wealthy or if you're a middle class,
you'd have this operation in your home.
You just have it on like your kitchen table,
which is,
which would have been safer than going into the hospitals.
Yeah.
Because the hospitals were crawling with all kinds of infection.
So hospitals were places for the poor.
And um,
to give you an idea of how gross it was,
the bug catcher who had read on the beds of lights,
he was paid more than the doctors and surgeons in this time.
Yeah.
Cause,
I mean that's pretty important,
right?
There's maggots,
all kinds of things crawling around in these hospitals.
So if you are wealthy or middle class,
you had your search and come to your home.
And so she,
uh,
has a surgeon come and the surgeon determines that yes,
the bras has to come off and says,
I'm going to return,
but I'm not going to tell you the day,
which would make me more anxious.
He thought it was going to help her not focus on it,
but all you would be thinking about right is one is this guy and his show up.
That's a person without breasts.
Yeah,
exactly.
He was like,
I'll just show up.
It'll be easy.
Um,
and so he shows up and he goes into her bedroom and he opens his hand and shows
her the knife he's going to use.
And he says to prepare her soul for death.
But this isn't very confidence inspiring.
Any doctors listening don't tell your patients to prepare their soul for depth.
And um,
and she's,
she does survive.
And she talks about how it's so vascular that the blood blinds him at one point.
And so like just when you think it can't get worse,
he can't see and he's under,
um,
she is under his hand for an hour and a half.
He cuts away and she survived.
She and she ends up living a long and somewhat happy life.
I'm sure she had a lot of nightmares.
Yeah.
There we see us.
Do they tie this woman down?
Like how do they oh yeah,
they would have definitely had to restrain her.
I mean people were probably a little bit stronger or more able to adapt to pain
than we are.
But nonetheless,
there would have been some pretty heavy restraint.
That was in the 1840s when cancer common
or was it always common human?
Yeah,
that's,
that's a good question.
The oldest archeological record I believe is 2000 years old of metastatic
cancers.
So it's older than you think.
There are,
um,
diagnosing head for for centuries and centuries.
I'm not really an expert in history of cancer,
but it is around.
And so with breast cancer,
you know,
probably by the time it got to the stage of mastectomy it probably would have
spread.
If you think about like you know,
it being visible to the naked eye,
but yet she survived.
She did survive.
And so then you have to question whether she had breast cancer or maybe it was
some kind of just like,
yeah,
maybe a cyst.
And she went through that for that.
But yeah,
and again,
before antiseptics before lister comes on and comes up with germ fighting
techniques,
this would have been so dangerous because you have this open cavity and wounds.
And so Joseph Lister,
when he comes up with his antiseptic techniques,
he actually performs a mastectomy on his sister,
on his dining room table.
Oh.
Which,
and she survives.
And that's in the book.
See this,
this would be a great movie,
Don't you think?
Do think it would be a great movie.
It's like it would be a great moment for the Cohen Brothers.
Yeah.
Cause it's so chaos Phil.
I know.
And all of that kind of grittiness and yeah.
Period pieces to yeah,
they could make it more entertaining.
This happen.
Joe.
No Polish,
not a part of that world.
But this guy with the face where they cut that tumor out of his face.
So for 24 minutes,
that's all it took to cut that thing out of his face
and that,
that case.
Yeah.
And remember of course it depended on the skill of your surgeon.
So he goes to a very good surgeon named James Syme.
Um,
but there,
there was a story.
So going back to penises,
um,
there's lithotomy as the removal of the stone,
which you saw kind of a,
a,
a demonstration there.
Um,
and it was incredibly painful.
So they stuck a rod down the penis and they cut through the scrotum.
They remove the stone.
And of course there was no pain medication and it was just awful.
Did they drink it?
You know,
it's kind of a myth because of course drinking within your blood.
But someone asked me,
they said,
I heard that surgeons would punch the patient out.
And I was like,
Oh,
you'd have to be really good to knock someone out.
On a first punch and of course you do more damage.
You could do a lot of damage to the hat.
That's definitely didn't happen unless someone can prove me wrong.
Maybe there's like a weird example,
but I've never come across that.
Um,
so,
so it was kind of,
it was you and the surgeon and um,
with the lithotomy it takes about a good surgeon who took about five minutes.
Well,
there's a guy named Steven Polaroid in 18,
28 who goes in to have this done now.
It's incredibly embarrassing.
It's your,
you know,
your naked from the waist down.
It's an embarrassing operation.
It's painful.
He's broadened the theater and the surgeon ends up taking over an hour because
he's so inept and the patient is screaming,
Yo,
please just stop.
Just stop.
And um,
and the surgeon yells back at him for having an abnormal,
which,
how would you like that?
You're sitting there on the,
on the table and you're being blamed for this going wrong.
And he pulls through the operation,
but he does die a post operative infection.
Abnormal anatomy.
How so?
He just said,
you have abnormal anatomy.
And so on the autopsy report,
it was revealed that there was nothing abnormal about his anatomy.
The surgeon just was really announced.
Oh yeah.
It wasn't good blaming the guy.
I did you have lunch before this?
Yeah,
I did,
but I'm all right.
Good.
That's,
well,
that's good because then you won't faint.
Right.
I hosted fear factor for sex.
True.
I've seen everything.
Yeah.
It was nothing.
What's the worst?
I mean,
was there ever a segment on fear factor that you thought,
Ooh,
I don't know if I can watch that.
No,
no.
Uh,
uh,
when they had a drink come,
that was rough.
Oh yeah.
That was what got the show cancel.
Yeah.
That was a,
the second version of your factor when it came back for a brief period of time
and they were going way too hard.
They were trying to do themselves further.
Yeah.
They were like fear factors back and it's crazier than ever and they just went
way over the top.
They do a TV.
Right.
You just always pushing the boundaries.
He didn't have to.
Yeah,
because it was just gone with regular fear factor.
And we would have all been fine.
We could do historical fear factor,
we can recreate these sorts of horrible things.
It was a blessing in disguise.
But,
um,
this,
this surgery as we know it,
when did it first start?
Like what is the first historical recounting of an actual doctor?
Oh,
or you mean on someone?
Someone saying they're a licensed doctor.
When did it start?
Like,
like really hard questions.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
No,
no,
I know so little about history.
I,
it's like 19th,
18th century.
Um,
it's,
it,
you know,
we have evidence again in the archaeological records of,
of surgical procedures going far back.
But who did them?
They would have been,
um,
you know,
sometimes why they called him wise women comedy.
Connie women on barber surgeons.
So one of my,
yeah,
with the borrower.
Very good at razors,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Actually Barber surgeons used to do things like pull your teeth.
They used to blog wet.
And so the Barber Pole,
which is right in white is right and white because it was advertising their
services is blood ladders.
So what they would do,
they would tie these bloody rags around the pole and it would whip around the
pole.
I know it's one of my favorite stories.
And um,
and the,
the ball at the top represented the bowl that would catch the blood and the
stick would have been the stick that you held to kind of get your veins to stick
out and people were blood let for all kinds of reasons.
Like you would do it like a purge or a diet or,
or you would do it because you were ill.
Um,
the idea being that you had produced too much blood and you needed the blood to
be let to kind of restore balance in your body.
What do you think it would be like to go back in time and hear someone say
something that's stupid?
Like,
you're sick.
We need to remove some of your blood.
Do you have too much blood in your system?
You're going to show,
you're going to send all of these like crazy historians who are like,
we can't.
Yeah,
there you go.
There's,
you got the tons Sorial services.
What does that mean?
And you know what else the barber shop quartet comes from?
The idea that the barber surgeons often had a musical loot in the office that
you would play or the patient would play was like a musical therapy.
Um,
so there's all kinds of hangovers from it.
And you know the demon barber,
a Sweeney Todd.
Yeah.
So this is kind of a,
one of these stories that pops up and they think that it might be that medical
practitioners,
we're trying to um,
undermine the legitimacy of the barbers.
So you kind of either get this story that the barber,
is this like sort of demon figure who's chopping you up and selling you in
making you into pies?
Or
is that a legit one?
Because that seems like nonsense.
Well it seems like it's a recreation of it seem older one cause,
well it seems like parody.
Like,
look,
it says,
listen to my troubles.
No charge.
Listen to your troubles.
50 cents.
They might've had that on there.
Barbered thing.
When they're cutting bolts out of you,
it's as bullets removed.
Two Bucks.
I don't know.
They're all drunk.
Pomade,
mustache wax.
Yeah.
People,
people thought that bullets were,
uh,
that gun powder was poisonous.
So a surgeon would often amputate if you were shot.
Oh God.
Until they kind of realize that sometimes it was okay to just keep the bullet in
depending on,
on where it was.
But it could just be like a recreation of something that someone found maybe.
And there's selling that as a piece maybe,
right?
Probably.
Yeah.
And we get the,
we get the red,
blue and white barber polls now.
So what happened was the barber surgeons and the surgeons split off
professionally at some point in history.
And so the surgeons start to use blue and white poles and the barber's used
right.
And White Poles.
And I think now the red,
white and blue is like the patriotic red,
white and blue.
But,
but the traditional barber pole would have been right in white and it would have
signified that you could come in and get your blood lighting because those,
those bloody rags would have been out there on the pole.
Um,
before they had the pole,
they would advertise by putting just bowls of congealed blood in the window.
Oh.
And then in London they decided,
I think it was about the 14th century,
they said no more of that.
So the barbers started to throw the blood into the river,
which was also equally gross.
Yeah.
So the barber surgeons would have definitely,
um,
been doing minor surgical procedures and they would have been more affordable
than the surgeons and the physicians themselves.
Um,
but nobody could really do much for you in that period according to our own sort
of 21st and unders,
you know,
it's 21st century understanding.
Um,
but I always say,
to go back to your question about,
you know,
um,
how would it feel to hear something so dumb?
Well,
what do you think today that,
you know,
in a hundred years we're going to look back at and there's,
there's definitely going to be stuff,
right,
that we're going to look back and go,
I can't believe that,
you know,
we used to see that.
In fact,
I,
I think that this is probably going to get people to go,
no,
that totally works.
You know,
that,
um,
uh,
trend of copying.
Yeah.
Now that you see,
so that also it's 17th century.
So they would cop,
they would have these heated cops and they would create this blister and then
they would cut it open with this really sharp instrument and that's how they
would bleed you.
So it's kind of this weird thing that's coming back,
but for slightly different reasons.
I don't think there's any evidence of comping is real.
No,
I don't think so either.
And I,
and I like to point people to the past because if we're going to make fun of,
you know,
what they were doing in the past,
it's kind of making a reappearance so to speak.
Um,
but people do all kinds of weird things now too.
Like they eat the placenta.
There's,
I,
there is no medical evidence that,
that has any kind of health benefit.
It's edible oil.
Yeah.
Can eat it.
Well,
it's funny because that actually segues into,
into this lovely object,
this half skull here.
My friend Zane Wylie creates these,
these are actually cereal bowls.
But,
uh,
and the reason why I brought it was because it opens up a conversation about
something that I like to talk about,
which is corpse Madison.
So people used to actually eat dead bodies for medicinal purposes.
Um,
so if you had epilepsy and the early modern period,
so when we were like talking like 16th,
17th,
18th centuries,
um,
people would drink the blood of an executed criminals.
Someone who lost their head.
Like the idea was that the life cut short,
that the blood was very powerful force.
And so you get these sort of,
um,
drawings of people gathered at the scaffold.
You know,
this poor pastor's going to lose his head.
And these people were like holding cups up to catch the blood.
And it didn't work in epilepsy was so awful because it was so misunderstood.
And you can imagine,
you know,
when someone goes into a seizure,
it's,
um,
it's scary.
And if you don't understand what's happening,
you could think that it's witchcraft or there's all kinds of things that,
um,
people thought about that disease.
So these people were quite desperate,
so they were drinking the blood of executed criminals.
They ground up,
um,
mummy's ancient mummies and they would make it into pills and did all kinds of
things.
Right.
So I,
so I always point this out,
we eat the placenta today.
It's kind of like,
you know,
a form of I'm ingesting bodily.
Yeah.
See,
there you go.
Yeah.
So people were just super,
super desperate back then.
Yeah.
I mean,
of course there was not much that could be done right.
But,
but we do some kind of form of corporate medicine and organ donation.
So we're taking dead body parts were not eating them,
but we're taking them into our body to cure ourselves.
Cadaver graft on my right knee.
Oh yeah.
I have one in my jaw.
I had,
well,
I had a guy,
a huge fist fight and no,
um,
I had,
uh,
some gum disease up here and then they had to like graphed a little light piece
of cadaver bone,
but they don't call it cadaver bone.
Did they call it,
get everyone to you?
Don't they call it freeze dry bone or something?
No,
it wasn't bone.
It was a,
they call it an Allo graft.
It's a cadaver.
The use the Achilles tendon for the ACL because the Achilles tendon
is much larger than an ACL.
So it's stronger and if you don't,
are you familiar with the way it works is really kind of interesting the way it
works.
It's not like it takes over,
it sound like an organ transplant so you don't,
you don't have to worry about your body rejecting it in the same way.
Although some people,
sometimes people's bodies don't accept it or it doesn't work,
but um,
they ticked this graft,
they put this new tendon in place,
this new a ligament in place rather,
and then your body re proliferates that ligament with cell.
So it's,
even though it will feel like it's healed up within like a month or two,
like you're,
you're Neil feel a little bit weak from the surgery,
but people get a distorted perception of how strong it actually is.
And fighters in particular,
I know several fighters who have wound up reinjuring their need because they
thought it was okay.
I'm real.
Really.
It was very gummy and very weak.
So how long does it take to heal before like six months.
Yeah.
Like six to nine months.
They recommend,
but it's amazing what we can do now.
I know incredible about 150 years ago that I'm talking about and today.
Yeah.
It's just the,
and,
and I always,
because I'm a big Joseph Lister Fan,
I always say that if we hadn't understood germs,
there would be no way to go deep into the body would there.
Sure.
Yeah.
Um,
and so he opens up this sort of huge field with Madison and a lot of advanced,
uh,
advancements are made off the back of it.
But,
um,
but it was,
it was a gritty time and um,
it definitely,
you definitely could die very easily.
Life was very cheap back then.
Yeah.
I mean,
I can only imagine just the idea that woman getting her breasts removed on her
kitchen table.
Yeah.
There was another,
there was a little boy,
he was 12 years old.
His name was Henry pays.
And he was told by the surgeon he had to have his leg removed and he sighed as
little kids do,
would it hurt?
And the surgeon said no more than having a tooth polled.
Oh cool.
So he was very unprepared.
So they brought him into the operating theater and he was so awake.
And so where he remembers counting six strokes of the saw before is a little leg
fell off.
Why?
They have to cut his leg off.
He broke it and
it was just a sprain and they just decided to take it off.
No,
I mean if there was a compound fracture,
the chances of it on becoming infected was quite high.
So when lister comes along and he's trying to figure out what's causing the
infection,
he notices that if it's a clean break and there's no break in the skin,
usually it heals.
Okay.
But if there's a break in the skin,
it gets infected and usually it leads to some kind of gang green or septicemia.
And that's how he starts to wonder.
It must be something coming from outside and getting into this wound that is
causing the infection.
But he breeds Louis Pasteur's germ theory and this is how he starts to put it
together.
But when he first comes out with it,
you know,
there's a lot of pushback because medicine and science are essentially
conservative in the sense that it's like puzzle solving.
If someone,
you know,
you,
you solve the puzzle within the rules that are already set out.
If someone from sort of the fringe and has this wild idea,
usually there's a lot of pushback.
And so that's exactly what happens with lister.
And it's hard for us to imagine because germs,
we understand them today,
it seems obvious to us,
but back then a surgeon didn't wash his hands or his instruments because why
would he wash his hands or his instruments if they were going to get dirty with
the next patient?
So you have to get into the mind,
the logical mind of a Victorian surgeon.
They were aprons.
I think Jamie,
I'd also send a picture of like a surgeon with,
with his apron on.
Actually it's a picture of a butcher.
Um,
but it gives you that kind of idea of,
of what your friendly Victorian surgeon would have been wearing and um,
that apron,
the more blood it had on it,
it was like a sign of pride almost because that meant that your surgeon was very
experienced and have the bottom a lot of it.
That is a butcher.
Yeah.
Tools.
The trade.
Yep.
Similar tools.
And,
and certainly that apron would have been on your surgeon.
Yeah,
I know.
It's kind of like gangs of New York,
you know,
you kind of,
you kind of picture,
they would warn those really tall top hats and um,
those crazy plaid colors.
And it's,
it's a very colorful time before Victoria course plunges the nation into
morning,
um,
later.
So listers coming in along the 1840 [inaudible].
It's very sort of colorful and filthy and dirty.
And the choice in the morning when her husband died,
um,
she went into sort of lifetime morning.
So she's always wearing black for the rest of her life and everybody follows her
example.
So we think of the Victorians wearing sort of all that black,
but in gangs of New York,
a lot of people thought that that was sort of an imagined world,
but actually that's what they would've looked like.
They would have been wearing those plaids and those bright colors and those top
hats.
But lister was a Quaker,
we think of like Quaker oats,
which is kind of accurate.
Um,
and he would have been wearing sort of black and white and very dull colors.
So when I think about this movie,
because I think about it a lot,
I think about sort of this world being very hedonistic and colorful and there's
a lot of drugs going on 'em they're discovering ether and all kinds of things
that they're experimenting with.
And then you have this somber Quaker and as the movie sort of progresses,
the world catches up and gets a bit cleaner with lister.
So they were experimenting with all these drugs?
Oh yeah.
It was like,
it was just a crazy time.
So ether is,
so my book begins with the first operation under anesthesia.
And I wanted to start there because I think if anybody has ever thought about
the history of surgery,
which they might not have until they turned into this podcast,
they tend to think of that moment.
That's the big moment.
But actually surgery becomes much more dangerous because the surgeon still
doesn't understand germs,
but he doesn't have the patient fighting him anymore.
So He's more willing to pick up the knife and go deeper in the body.
And so postoperative infection rises and it,
and it opens with the Great Robert Liston.
And he performed the first operation under ether in 1846 in London.
And um,
and he doesn't think it's going to work.
It comes from America.
He calls it the Yankee Dodge.
Um,
and it's a miracle.
It works in the age of agony is over.
When ether was discovered,
everybody wanted to try it.
That's drug that made you insensible.
What was that like?
And so you get these kinds of stories of medical students sniffing it and
drinking it.
In fact,
I believe there's still a place in London.
You can get an ether cocktail again.
I don't,
I don't endorse it.
It's highly flammable.
So people also smoked a lot in operating theaters.
So you can imagine that there were a lot of gather a lot of accidents,
but,
but you drop it on a basically because it evaporates really quickly.
You drop it on a strawberry and then you dunk it into champagne and it's
supposed to get you really high very quickly and then it wears off equally
quickly.
I tried to convince my publisher to have ether cocktails book launch,
but they were like,
just have a bunch of Uber's ready.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Or carriage is like in the Victorian.
Um,
so,
so people were,
yeah,
definitely trying.
And then of course I have not tried it.
I haven't found that bar.
Yeah.
Experiment on the people that came to your book.
Wow.
That'd be the best thing.
Great Story.
You know,
instead of people.
Yeah.
Maybe,
maybe try it out maybe for the next book.
But uh,
yeah.
And so,
so you have ether in sort of the mid 19th century,
and then of course later you have cocaine.
You have on opium,
which is,
um,
well actually cocaine comes along and is presented as sort of a,
a cure to the opiate,
the morphine addiction.
So like take cocaine instead.
And I had brought,
it's in my Mary Poppins bag.
Um,
I'll show it to you later.
After the show,
I brought a postcard that shows a dentist and he's pulling a tooth and the
person wrote underneath,
just had a tooth pulled with cocaine.
So they were,
they were using it for all kinds of things and doctors were becoming addicted
themselves to these drugs.
Um,
then heroin comes along,
they're invents heroin,
heroin is given to your children.
It's putting all kinds of things.
Again,
it's,
um,
it's positioned as,
you know,
break your cocaine addiction now with heroin.
So it just,
it wasn't just a crazy period and it was really in sort of in the early 20th
century when a lot of this stuff's starting to be regulated finally.
Wow.
I didn't bring any of that with me.
I believe
there was a mummy that was found in ancient Egypt that tested positive for
cocaine.
Oh.
But they think that it might be a false positive because apparently there's
something else that they would consume back then that would make you test
positive for cocaine.
I don't know.
Yeah,
Jamie,
you'll find it.
But there was,
it was some,
it was some Evans.
I think what they were trying to connect is to it.
Now.
I remember they were trying to connect this to the idea that people from Egypt
had the ability to travel to the Americas and that someone from here it goes,
American drugs in ancient Egyptian mummies can make it a little larger.
Pluse it says,
it seems safe to say Blah,
blah,
blah.
In 1992,
a new study of nine mummies from ancient Egypt created quite a stir.
When is announced the discovery traces of nicotine and cocaine in their hair.
Both of these chemicals came from plants found only in South America.
And this research has since been touted as evidence of Pre-colombian contact
between American Africa.
Something thought to be impossible based on the rest of the archeological
record.
So what's going on?
Let's start by looking at the evidence.
Uh,
Buh Buh,
Buh Buh Buh [inaudible] to the perform buys of Svelte da Ba Blah ba Nova and
two,
that's a serious woman.
And two of her colleagues at the Institute for Anthropology and,
well this is,
uh,
in Munich,
they're using German words for anthropology probably in humanities of university
a tests were carried out by nine mummies,
uh,
on nine mammies Munich museum dating from a 170 to 395 BC.
This study focused on hair samples,
which are offering used to,
uh,
assess drug concentrations in the body due to do the results.
Was it,
so here,
what they discovered all the mommies tested positive for cocaine and hashish,
which makes sense.
The results caused an immediate stir with the,
c'mon,
let's cut to the chase here folks.
First thing to say,
archeologist and not just being stubborn about this,
they're many reasons not to think the traces of drugs and nine mummies means
what does it,
what does it conclusion?
Cut to the chase.
He parks.
Yeah.
Nicotine.
Cocaine.
Okay.
Back Up.
Cocaine.
Stop.
Okay.
Cocaine.
Most of the thing of today was first discovered early civilizations,
the Andean region of South America,
that shoe and the coca leaves.
Exactly.
Instead the cocaine and possibly the nicotine to,
we're actually being introduced to the mummies as part of an embalming process.
Huh.
That's interesting.
Whoa.
More likely the obtain cocaine from America.
Okay.
I Dunno.
I'd give up.
There's no way that we'll have to read this.
I tried.
It just seems like it's going to take a long time.
Many residents and spices hold on a second.
Worst certainly used this day.
We're aren't entirely sure what they all were rare or exotic materials we'll
almost certainly used.
And it is far less of a stretch to suggest this included imports from the Middle
East and potentially as far afield as India.
Hm.
I Dunno.
I think they,
this,
they're very skeptical about the idea that people from Egypt,
uh,
we're able to travel all the way to the Americas where cocaine was.
But I think,
I think part of the conclusion was that there were some other things that would
make that you test positive for cocaine.
Oh,
it's interesting.
It will sort of like poppy seeds make you test positive for her.
Did you have to go for a drug test for work?
They say don't eat poppy seed Bagel.
Wasn't there like a Seinfeld?
I'm looking at the Wikipedia for it.
It might've been part of a thriving tourist scam and Egypt and the Victorian
area.
So they might have like said it was there and so people would come look and then
you know,
wait a minute,
said what was there to cocaine?
It says since passing this corpses off recently deceased as ancient mommy's was
a thriving tourists scam and Egypt or in Victoria.
Like I could have a,
I'm to,
I'll put it doesn't make sense because the tests were done in after the
experiments.
Even assuming the cocaine was actually found on the mummies.
It's possible this could have been a contamination that occurred after this
governor.
So bunch of coke heads were fondling.
Money's,
yeah,
well they,
it does Mommy's cause they wanted to eat them as I said,
you know,
they ground them up.
And did you use it at all the ancient Egyptian mummies that you started to think
about?
How much was destroyed.
People had to eat it all the time.
This is a fantastic,
um,
uh,
exhibit Carol.
Mark cure all mummy powder.
Wow.
Look at that.
That is nuts.
Mummy extract.
It's a cure all whatever you got.
Yeah.
Fix it.
You know,
it's,
you know,
it's a quack remedy when it's a cure all,
we still have clamp remedies,
you know,
take a pill,
lose weight
my back and things that are causing people to lose weight.
And those late night infomercials.
Yup.
Take a bunch of pills.
Yeah.
That's your modern day quackery.
There's a fantastic exhibit that's uh,
right now there's an imax exhibit in Los Angeles at one of the museums.
I saw it about a year ago,
but they have a King Tut exhibit.
And then,
um,
on top of that they have this gigantic imax theater,
which is fantastic.
And they show the,
all these different tombs that they had discovered and how they discovered them.
And,
but it makes,
it makes you really,
when they've discovered King Tut's tomb,
we have no idea how many similar tombs there were that were looted over the
years.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
what we have,
you know,
in the museums,
it's just sort of a fraction of what we know and it's still stuff is coming to
light.
It's just incredible.
Yeah.
Um,
but yeah,
they,
the Victorians are responsible for destroying a lot for taking those mummies
and,
and just grounding them off and all kinds of things.
Yeah.
What gets me is,
what was the mode like where was the theory?
Like what did the theory come from?
Like when you want to take a mummy and making it a powder,
some of it would have been sort of folk Madison influence.
Um,
you know,
there's,
there's this idea of sympathetic magic.
So,
um,
for instance,
if,
uh,
you,
if I stabbed you with a sword,
it's get very violent.
Um,
you could be healed.
If I put this sort of special sympathetic powder on the sword,
it would heal you.
So it was sort of this on healing by distance.
So all kinds of strange ideas existed,
but,
and that's why it's important when you're studying history medicine to really
get into the mindset because it's so wildly different to the way we think.
Right.
Um,
and,
and you know,
actually,
do you know what this is?
I brought this son,
if people are just listening,
it's,
it's a long beat mask and like a burn ban side.
Yeah,
no,
I do not know what that is.
Okay.
So this,
a lot of people think this is a venetian mass.
This is actually particularly on a particular example from Venice.
It is,
um,
what people would have doctors would have worn during the vaneck plague.
So it's called the play doctor mask.
And so,
um,
it was invented in the 17th century,
by a French doctor.
And the idea behind it was so people thought that disease was spread by this
thing called Miasma,
which are like little particles in the air.
They're sort of associated with bad smells.
So if something smells bad,
it's probably not good for you,
is what they thought.
And it kind of makes sense because if like,
you know,
you're in a really,
um,
if you're in a slummy area of the Victorian period,
it's probably has a lot of disease.
It probably doesn't smell good.
So that was sorta the thinking behind it.
So what you would do is you would put sweet smelling herbs into the beak and so
you would be smelling the scent.
It would protect you from those evil miasma.
Yeah.
And you know,
is that a real one?
No,
we don't actually have,
um,
I don't believe there's an example of a real one from the 17th century,
but there's a lot of illustrations of the plate doctor and he would have been
wearing a hat.
He would have been wearing a cape,
um,
leather gloves,
like sort of just protecting himself.
Oh,
there you go.
That's a real one.
Authentic 16th century plague,
Dr Mask preserved and,
and display at the
museum of medical history.
But I questioned that because it was invented in the 17th century.
So if it's real,
it's going to be a little bit later.
Um,
but we don't know how much they were warm because they would have been
expensive.
A lot of doctors weren't very noble,
so the plate broke out.
They got the hell out of there.
Um,
there was sort of a phrase go far and go long,
you know,
get out and don't come back for a while.
It wasn't much they could do for you.
They had a stick as well that they would sort of poke the patient with so they
wouldn't have to touch the patient and kind of have them turn over and they can,
you know,
yes,
you have the plague.
There wasn't much they could do for you.
Um,
we can cure the place.
They did not know what Wa,
what germs were,
what the plague was.
They had sort of a concept of,
of contagion.
So if you broke out with the plague,
they would probably quarantine you in your house.
Um,
and they put a big cross on the door and so people would bring food and um,
you,
um,
you know,
put a basket outside of your window with a rope and you take,
and so they do that until everybody was dead in the house or that the plague and
passed.
And they felt that you were a safe to come out into the general population.
So there was an idea that these things were contagious but not again in the way
that we kind of understand disease diseases being spread today.
So strange that they would,
would not know what was going on.
Like people dying and you'd be like,
what is it?
You would think it was yeah,
it could be God's curse on,
uh,
and,
and people say,
you know,
oh,
the plague mask is so terrifying.
Um,
it's super creepy,
but I always say that it's good luck.
This is why I brought this across.
The Atlantic said Joe Rogan could,
where the plague,
Dr Mask,
how many people would know what that is?
Like if you went,
you know what,
you go into faculty,
they say play Doctor Mask.
Right.
It's funny cause I was just in Venice recently and they were saying that,
you know,
the big carnival,
um,
that they have every year,
it's becoming harder to do because of security reasons.
So you have like a huge population of his city wearing masks and covering their
identities.
They have to cut back,
which kind of sucks cause you know,
that's like the fun of the carnival.
Um,
so now they're,
they're,
um,
uh,
cutting back where you can wear them in public places and things like that.
But um,
world we live in.
Yeah,
it is.
It is.
Unfortunately,
we're a plague mass.
Can't wear a plague mass.
I'm going to bring it back though.
I'm just going to be walking around in downtown La.
Wow.
Would that attached to your face exclusively straps or something?
Yeah,
there would have been straps or I'm in that other example he was showing it
looked like it was sort of a foreign,
I mean,
that looks so creepy.
It's so creepy.
But death today we have the modern play doctor.
What,
what do you think that would be?
Yeah,
the,
the Hazmat.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
And so you think about the Hazmat going into hot zones,
that would be pretty scary if you didn't know what was going on.
And certainly sort of ominous,
you know,
when you see the Hazmat.
So it,
it's a weird thing that exists because in a strange kind of way,
probably did protect the play doctor because he was covering himself up,
but it protected him for the wrong reasons.
He still didn't understand how disease was spreading.
Are you aware of the theory of alien abduction being a distant memory of
childbirth?
No.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a theory that is actually being tossed about that these people that have
this ancient,
well,
they have this memory of childbirth,
right?
So all of a sudden you're being born,
there's bright lights above you.
There's a man or a woman who's the surgeon with a mask that covers their face.
So all you see is their eyes and that everything looks bright and it's
terrifying and clinical and you're on this table and everything's cold.
Most of these alien abduction experiences that people recount,
they'd take place in some sort of a,
a medical facility and everything is bright and strange and cold.
And they think that what this is,
is there.
They're saying that we had this idea that children don't have memories,
that babies don't have memories.
And so they're saying,
well,
why wouldn't they have memory?
So it's ridiculous.
Of course they had memories.
They have brains.
They,
they grab your finger,
they looked you in the eye.
They would have a memory of every second that they were born.
And it's probably one of the most profound and disturbing memories because
before that,
everything is incredibly peaceful inside the mother's womb.
You know,
you're just like taken out,
hold out.
And then there's this bright light above you.
You'd never experienced any lights.
Yeah.
So every and your visual perception,
your field of views all distorted,
right.
This is the first time you're using your eyes.
That's why people have the same into
this memory.
Yes.
Early memory.
That's interesting.
This a theory.
It makes sense to me because of you.
Well,
it's more sense then the abduction.
Yeah.
So well does,
because people don't really go anywhere.
See,
the thing about the abduction thing is they've put like cameras in people's
rooms and a,
and they say they have these alien abduction experiences,
but they don't go anywhere.
So what they're doing is they're dreaming and which is
the mind is amazing and it's so powerful and we know so little still.
Yeah.
So like these all these,
I mean it's,
it's kind of Duh because they all happened while you're sleeping.
Yeah.
90 plus percent.
They tend to be medical.
Yeah.
It's very medical in nature,
right.
You're being examined.
And then there's also going back to childbirth.
There's also a lot of people that have these experiences that they are being
told that either they're taking their baby away from them or they're studying
their baby or that they had a baby inside of them that they know about and that
the aliens have put it there and they're taking it out.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
it even goes back to the virgin birth,
right?
I mean,
it's all,
yeah,
it's all very weird.
But this,
uh,
this memory that people have from childhood is a most likely,
you know,
probably a pretty intense,
powerful interests memory that's always there.
Yeah.
And if your first memory yeah.
And some people can tap into it and some people can't.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
This is what,
it's also a theory,
while natural childbirth is supposed to be less traumatic,
like women having natural child birth in a bathtub,
you know,
that that is actually kind of
like moving back to,
you know,
it's um,
men start to get involved in child birth around the 17th century,
18th century,
what I'm before it was mostly women.
So women in the village would come and actually the term,
um,
gossip comes from the idea of the women who would spread the word in the village
that someone was going into labor,
they were called the gossips.
So they spread the word sort of a negative thing later so that the gossips would
spread the word.
The women would come in.
This was a female only chamber on and men were not really allowed in.
A man might be brought in if the mother was dying or if the child was dying.
And then in that case,
instruments were brought into the birth,
the birth in chambers.
So the doctor might come in and he might,
um,
take these sort of forceps and pick the baby apart and take the baby out and the
baby would die.
But in those cases,
it was like really extreme.
Like this was gonna happen.
Like either the mother was going to die,
the baby was going to die,
both from we're going to die or if the baby was coming out feet first.
Yeah.
Midwife capable midwife could,
could handle that on.
But this,
you know,
this is Syrian section.
People think that it comes from the term that the idea that Julie Caesar was
ripped from the womb of his mother.
Right.
But it's unlikely that that story is true because his mother lives into old age.
So probably the,
the terms of Syrian comes from the Latin term meaning to cut.
And the first sort of a record
we have of this happening I think is in the 16th century and it's a farmer and
he takes the instruments that he uses to castrate as pigs to cut this baby out
of his wife.
Um,
yeah.
And,
and we don't have any records of whether this is probably didn't work again,
no idea of germs,
all this kind of stuff.
Um,
but yeah,
I don't have,
there's no sort of,
it doesn't follow the records.
Don't follow the story but she probably died and the baby probably died as well.
Oftentimes castrate them and then let them loose because then they suck.
They concentrate on grass and not ass.
That is a actual farmers term.
I have,
you know,
talking about the Syrian sections and castrating pigs who knew those two things
when
the joint as cautious
as a steers castrated castrate them because they make better stakes.
Things I learned on don't muscular jacked bowl.
No,
probably not being very chewy and
the buffalo above my friend Adam Green tree shot that in Australia and the,
my friend Cam was chewing on a piece of his for one piece for half an hour.
Oh my gosh.
It was bad.
I guess that makes sense.
2000 pound sack of steel is not good.
Then you want to sit down and have a meal?
No,
I mean,
they say they very,
like sometimes some of them you can eat.
I mean,
you can eat them.
They're all buffalo,
but they're just insanely dense.
Crazy.
How big,
I mean,
when you see the skull,
it's just the size of it is incredible.
It's a,
it's also an invasive species,
so they have no natural predators.
There's just thousands and thousands of,
I'm destroying the countryside.
People travel up to the northern lands,
Art Island,
I forget the name of the place where they go and they hunt these things.
Wow.
Yeah,
they're huge.
They are.
Australia is a trip.
I mean,
it wasn't really a wildlife experiment brought in so many animals and New
Zealand as well.
And they're not indigenous and they're just doing a lot.
Um,
so when you think about the history of surgery and that you,
you concentrate on this one very particular time in this book,
in this book,
but as a medical historian,
like when,
what,
first of all,
what led you to that?
Like why you seem so normal thing?
Oh yeah.
I'm super normal.
Look at all these skulls and stuff in front of me.
Um,
I,
you know,
I'm like that kid who never grew out of the obsession with tales from the crypt,
Ripley's believe it or not,
you know,
the shrunken heads.
I actually did a
segment for documentary in the shrunken heads and I had to go out to Poland.
I actually got to hold these things that I was always fascinated with growing up
where people don't know that they think the skulls in there.
That's why they don't understand what's happening to shrink your head.
And it's,
it's amazing because I'm,
what they do
is that you obviously like they take the Skoll out and it's a process and this
documentary was looking at,
they were DNA testing them because the tribe that makes these skulls,
they were done for a specific purpose to trap the soul of the warrior that they
killed.
So that there was a spiritual reason behind it.
But what they were finding was that some of these shrunken heads were female.
Um,
which probably means that,
um,
as Westerners came into these areas,
they wanted to collect these shrunken heads is curiosities of course.
And so they traded guns for heads.
And so it kind of drove up the,
uh,
the demand for these,
these shrunken heads.
Well,
it wasn't just it,
just anybody and it might not have been killing them.
It might've just been taking bodies of people who had already died,
but they definitely aren't all authentic in the sense that they were,
um,
killed in battle.
And so it's just kind of an interesting,
but I got to interact and see the shrunken heads.
So I was that weird,
creepy kid that,
you know,
no one really wanted to talk to.
I joke that I was,
I also,
um,
looked like Barb from stranger things
and my brother pointed this out and we were watching stranger things and then
Barb dies and nobody gives a shit.
And I'm like,
yes,
sorry.
Sorry everybody.
Um,
and I was just devastated.
I'm like,
nobody noticed for,
you know,
like the whole season,
but they barely carrier.
I guess she's missing that.
No one cared about bars by the pool.
I was,
I was really awkward.
I was five,
seven by the age of 10.
And I was just,
I was just like that weird kid with tales from the crypt.
And so I kind of it.
So I went on to study history in college and then I went to Oxford and I did a
masters and phd in it.
But academia is not,
it's isn't,
doesn't allow me to be as creative and weird as I'd like to be.
So now I'm just a storyteller.
I'm a freelance writer and I do this youtube channel and I'm sure Oxford's going
to be like,
give us the peach phd back.
Can they do that?
No,
there's a real value in that in terms of education because what you do is very
interesting and entertaining.
I mean that's
tweeting your stuff.
It's really,
no,
I appreciate that.
You know,
it's funny because there is this sort of tension between what they call popular
history and academic history and I will get like academic historians will come
at me on Twitter and stuff and this one guy said to me,
well you're just an entertainer.
And I was like,
well that's not an insult to me.
Like that's why is that?
And it's true.
You have a phd,
like yeah,
it's stupid.
I should've just said that.
You know,
you're just an entertainer.
Yeah.
Just it's like,
it's like a bastardizing the subject and some kind of way that they don't like
it.
It's because of people like me,
I'm like,
Hey,
oh gross.
I retweet it.
I know.
Exactly.
And then it makes it,
and then they want it,
you know,
like I did this thread on Twitter called your Victorian doctors trying to kill
you.
And every tweet was like coke or rats,
cocaine laced cigarettes,
which you had also shared at one point and just all the kinds of crazy things.
And then at the end of the threat,
I said,
but what is it about today that people will,
will look back?
But you know,
this one academic was like,
this is,
um,
you know,
bad history and you're,
you're making it fun.
How dare you,
you know,
it's like that scene to vote.
Yeah.
Offense of that.
But for the most part,
people enjoy it and,
and that's nice.
The big complaint that people have about academia is that it's so stuffy.
Yeah.
I'm going to get like so many weird academic Trump.
I know,
it's just,
it's one of those things like I've had to make peace with,
um,
because I am a storyteller and if you look at my profile,
I call myself a storyteller first rather than historian stories.
Three stories for us in 2019 are so incredibly fortunate to have actual real
doctors with real modern medicine to fix us.
Real tore down shows,
had probably five surgeries.
I know I had an appendectomy and it was,
it was amazing.
They use little tiny robotic instruments now and they,
they barely make,
you know,
I think the incisions like an inch long or something.
It's just had shoulder surgery and the,
the,
the actual cuts are like millimeters,
tiny little cuts.
You barely can see the scars.
It's amazing.
And you know,
with your knee surgery it was a,
an injury from activity.
Right.
You know,
and you think about people in the past,
they weren't necessary.
Well,
I mean there were,
there were sports and in competitions,
but mostly people were getting injuries from repetitive,
strenuous Labor that they were doing.
Um,
there's a story of a,
of a cab driver in the 18th century and he got this aneurism behind his knees.
So,
um,
the cab drivers in the 18th century where these high boots like riding boots and
it would rub at the back of the knee and it created this huge aneurysm.
And there was a surgeon named John Hunter in London who said,
well,
normally what you do is you would hack the leg off because if it pops right,
given pops are going to bleed out.
But he said,
I have an idea.
I want to cut into the lag and I want to tie off the blood supply to the
aneurysm.
I want to see if that works.
And it did.
And he saved this guy's leg.
And that's really important because remember these people had no options if they
couldn't work.
A lot of these
people think of aneurysm and think of a brain,
right?
It's like a,
um,
what's the,
what's the term?
It's um,
it's a specific kind of aneurysm.
It's almost like a balloon that appears on the outs,
sort of on the outside of that blood.
Big Sack of blood.
Just drain it.
That's what I would think
if you severed it.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Um,
I'd be like slow down doc.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't hack that leg drive this taxi bitch.
Yeah.
And if he had lost his leg,
it would have been.
And what's incredible about that story actually is that he,
that hunter saves the leg and then when the man dies,
right before he dies,
he knows he's going to die.
This is many years later,
he writes a letter and he wills his body to hunter.
So this is one of the first early examples,
uh,
to,
to take the lag and to open it up and dissect it and to see what happened.
And so that way it's on display at the surgeons.
Uh,
I'm sorry,
at the Royal College of Surgeons in London.
So they embalmed it a,
yeah.
Well he would have preserved it probably with on wax injections.
Almost like plastination,
like an early form.
Yeah.
That weird guy.
Um,
body worlds
very torn.
When I was walking around this because what a part of me was saying,
this is really fascinating.
And the other part of you is saying,
what is the difference between this and like fucking Ed gains house where he
made lampshades out of it?
Well,
yeah,
I mean one would hope that the difference is consent,
but I would hope though,
yeah,
one would hope,
well there has been controversies with certain acts,
exhibitions,
maybe not body worlds,
but there's been some spinoffs where there's been a question of where they got
those bodies.
And of course if,
if you're also going into sort of poor areas and asking people to hand over
their bodies,
is it really consent?
Because sometimes these families don't have money for funerals and there's other
incentives.
But I think my view is why,
you know,
it's,
it's given under the guise of science that we can only view dead bodies through
the lens of Science Day.
That's the only acceptable way.
But it really is art.
Um,
and I wished that it would just be more openly recognize is just art,
whether it's you're kind of thing or not,
because some of it is posed and really shocking ways that are unnecessary to
teach anatomy.
So,
so,
you know,
if you're going to say it's an anatomical lesson,
why does the person have to be posed in this sort of dramatic way?
So I think that,
you know,
it would be better if we just called it for what it was.
It's art and it's supposed to be provocative and shocking.
And that's why people come to see it and were morbidly curious is absolutely
interesting.
Yeah.
I mean,
and,
and people say,
oh my gosh,
uh,
the Victorians bought tickets,
the operating theater.
Well,
people come to my Instagram account,
you know,
I mean,
we're still morbidly curious.
Oh,
for sure.
It's really interesting that it's called a theater as well.
Did you ever see that movie with Benito Del Toro?
I think it was just the wolf man.
It was one of the more recent werewolf movies,
but he becomes a werewolf in the operating theater.
Oh.
The doctor's convinced.
The doctor's convinced that he's a mad man,
there's something wrong with him.
So they'd give him electric shock therapy.
It's different things.
And what's the period that it's supposed to be in this period?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's in London.
So yeah,
see me can find it.
It's kind of a crazy scene.
The doctors were experimenting with electricity a lot and galvanism and things
like kind of reanimating the corpses.
We'd get the story Frankenstein and they were also interested in how long do you
live or your conscience after,
um,
you're beheaded.
So there's these experiments,
these experiments during the French revolution where they're like shouting at
the heads to see if the heads will blink.
Um,
so
I'm sure we can't,
uh,
air this on youtube.
So this will only be us watching this.
Cause if we air it on youtube,
they'll don't do a,
see,
that's exactly what this theater's,
yeah.
He's like saying that he's going to kill all of them.
Like you,
you need to get outta here.
And they,
okay,
this doctor is a very arrogant and they're dealing with him and the moon turns
full and he starts freaking out.
And it's,
it's really interesting because if this was actually how they had patient
strapped in,
is that accurate?
Like the way that
chair is set up,
they would have the,
I mean,
so his feet,
it looked like his feet were on the ground so the chair would have been higher.
So it's feet would have sort of dangled.
That's one of the best ever.
And I'm a giant Werewolf Fan.
This is one of the best ever,
because this was actually done by Rick Baker,
who is the same guy who did an American Werewolf in London,
which is the Werewolf.
It's out in the hall.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
I took pictures of that.
Yeah,
everyone does.
But this is the modern version of it that they decided to make.
And you know,
the thing is that these guys are watching this and the doctors arrogant,
he has his back to the patient while he's discussing
and it does exactly what those peers would have looked like as well.
Yeah.
But they would have been just so crowded.
That is so strange though,
that this was like,
this was entertainment.
This was something that people wanted to say.
Well,
you know,
it wasn't just sort of the morbid curiosity.
It was also that the Victorians were obsessed with,
uh,
sigh scientific progress.
So they wanted to come in and see,
right.
I see that they want to see what there is to work of there now in the training
for people are listening.
Yeah.
This is,
it's not a good movie,
but it's a,
it's a great scene.
There's a bunch of great scenes in this movie I enjoy just because I love
Werewolf movies.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It would have been fun to shoot.
Yeah.
Well,
it's,
um,
it's also,
they decided in this movie to make it with minimal use of CGI and yeah.
What they decided to do was do it all with actuals.
Yeah.
Rubber masks and things like that.
Pretty ridiculous movie.
Or,
honestly,
it actually,
it's funny because,
um,
it sort of reminds me of,
of again,
listing the six two giant,
he got a patient on the table who had to have a bladder stone removed.
Remember how awful that was?
And this guy was like,
fuck it,
I'm not going to do it.
He jumps off the table,
he runs across the room,
locks himself in a closet and list Liston,
all six,
two of them chases this guy,
ripped the door off and just drags him back.
Oh my God.
So,
you know,
and that really happens again,
be a great movie.
Anybody listening?
Yeah.
Really pushing this movie.
Are you trying to sell that while you're out here?
No.
I mean,
I'm a guarantee you someone is listening.
I,
you know,
I could sell the rights to the book,
but I've held onto him when I'm developing them with my producing partner
because this book was born out of a lot of traumas.
So a couple of years ago I went through a really bad divorce and I was facing
deportation as a from the UK.
And so I had no money.
I,
they took my passport,
everything,
like I couldn't do anything.
So I wrote this book.
And so I always say that Joseph lister saved a lot of lives,
not least my own because it's kind of lifted me and it's been a rebirth.
Um,
so I really want to be involved in the process.
I've always been fascinated with movies.
I want to kind of see how the sausage is made so to speak.
You know,
if you're a writer and you just sell off the rights,
you're not,
you don't really have much creative input at all.
Um,
but yeah,
I just think that,
you know,
it's,
it's a great story because it's,
it sort of crosses with the,
with people who are interested in the horror genre,
right?
Cause you get the surgery,
the Victorian surgery,
but it's an uplifting story about something that changed the world and the way
we fundamentally understand it.
Who you envisioned playing lister?
I see Bradley Cooper.
Oh,
Jamie's like perfect.
Trying to think of someone else,
but yeah,
that's basically,
do every move here.
Yeah.
He's like a quintessential movie star,
right?
Is He is,
yeah.
I was thinking
Eddie Redmayne,
the British actor who's like,
he's so sweet,
and lister is a very sort of who's cycle he's in on fantastic beasts and where
to find them.
The Harry Potter,
he's,
he's a,
he's really big in Britain or benedict Cumberbatch.
Oh,
that guy's awesome.
Yeah,
but it extraction.
I think benedict Cumberbatch would like to play listing the six to guide because
it's,
it's a real theatrical role.
He's another guy who was awesome and everything.
Amazing.
Yeah.
So if you're listening Benedek he's killer in doc.
Dr Strange is another movie that's not the best movie in the world,
but he's killer in it and he's tall.
You know,
he could play listing,
you know,
we could bulk them out of bed and,
Aha.
There we go.
Would you like a role in this as maybe the patient and
the Guy Jumps off his dick?
Hannah,
you don't want to be the guy that dies when his coat is slashed.
Yikes.
Yeah.
I'll be that guy.
Be The guy with faith.
Ooh,
Gosh.
Yeah.
That's a good role.
So this book sort of,
you were in quite a bit of personal anguish yourself.
You have this deep attachment to it.
I can understand that.
It's my first book and I'm working on a new book on the history of plastic
surgery and fascinated with that as well.
It's interest.
So I'm,
I'm looking at a guy named Harold Gillies who was rebuilding soldiers faces
during World War One.
And if you've ever seen these guys photos,
I mean it's,
we have no problems.
You know,
you,
you think we have no problems in the 21st century when you look at these guys
because they've been shot through the face and the jaws are missing.
And Harold Gillies on really designs or starts plastic surgery as we know it.
And it was a time when losing a limb made you a hero but losing your face made
you a monster.
So these guys are really isolated and so what Gillies does is he gives them
their identity back.
So it starts on the battlefields of world one and it's going to kind of follow
Gillies throughout.
I like to do character driven stories,
even though there are 100% true.
I like to sort of follow medical history through the eyes of one particular
person.
Wow.
Yeah.
The,
the history of plastic surgery is fascinating to me and I'm hooked on that show.
Botched.
Oh yeah.
People always mentioned that.
So this is me watching box.
This is me all the time.
Like,
Jeez,
yeah,
it's Christ doing,
man.
Stop doing that.
What people put themselves through.
I started following some plastic surgeons on Instagram just to kind of know
what,
what they're doing today and thinking about the ethics of how they target people
on social media and how do we feel about that.
And I'm telling you,
I'm 37.
I'm feeling bad about my body.
I can't imagine if you were like 14 and awkward and you're Barb,
you know,
and you and you and you have access to these accounts and the effect it has on
young people on Instagram and everything.
I had Jonathan Haidt on the podcast who wrote this book,
the coddling of the American mind.
And,
uh,
one of the big things that he discusses his people comparing themselves to
others through social media and children,
particularly girls,
this higher instances of suicide,
cutting depression,
much higher instances of depression,
I believe.
Yeah.
I believe it too.
It's,
it's crazy.
And then you see someone like Kylie Jenner who transforms herself literally from
an Ugly Duckling into a beautiful swan and it's all done through the knife and
it's,
it's crazy.
That's the whole thing like that,
that kind of beauty is unattainable release.
Oh yeah.
This is,
this is Harold Gillies,
one of his patients on,
and why is the end,
yeah.
And what he did was he invented this thing called the tube pedicle where he
would take skin and he would basically create a tube and he can place it
somewhere on the face where the defect was in the blood supply would make it
attach.
And the guy did an incredible job.
I mean,
first for 19,
that was probably 1917 right there.
So that's like better than a lot of the people on box.
It really is.
Yeah.
The final product.
And that's Gillies down down there that um,
yeah,
that's another man.
No,
he was incredible.
And really when you think about what these guys went through to,
um,
so the,
so my book is starting with this guy named Pearcey Claire who shot for both
cheeks and his face is just blown off.
And to get off the battlefield was half the struggle because if your face is
blown off,
most of the time,
the stretcher bearers,
we'll just pass you up because they think you're going to die.
Um,
but it was a survivable wound.
And so just getting off the battlefield,
you know,
so you sit there for 12 hours,
maybe die in the process food,
you can't eat no food.
And that was the other thing.
So a lot of these guys died because well,
intending nurses would lay them down and if you don't have a jaw,
your tongue slips back into your throat and you choke or you suffocate.
Um,
so,
so just getting to Harold Gillies hospital,
so he starts this incredible facial,
um,
and jaw unit in Britain during the war.
Just to get there was a battle.
And then you have to go through all these painful operations.
And so I want to look at that.
And then of course,
like how does that become what we do today?
But equally,
I always tell people that botched is one form of plastic surgery.
But of course there's a lot of important surgeons doing reconstructive work.
Yeah.
You know,
and now we have face transplants,
which are incredible.
I don't know,
Jamie,
if you could find someone who said a face transplant,
but there are quite a few.
Yeah.
There's,
there's,
you know,
the,
I think the hardest part is finding the donor.
It's hard to get people to donate their organs as it is,
but think about a face.
It's so personal.
Yeah.
Um,
and the last one,
national geographic did a spread on it and it was,
um,
18 I think it was an 18 year old girl who was shot herself in the face and in a
moment of rage.
And I'm just thinking in,
in any way.
She ended up having this face transplant about three years later and the,
the donor face,
I think with someone who is in their thirties,
um,
this person had died I think of an overdose and then the family decided to give
this face over.
So it's,
it's actually incredible what we can do when you think about,
you know,
from the battlefields of World War One to what Gillies doing to where we are
today with facial reconstruction and it's just going to get better and better.
Yeah.
I'm sure it is going to get better and better.
And for people with disfiguring injuries and things,
it's fantastic.
Yeah.
What freaks me out about botched is the psychological aspect of people
constantly tinkering with their looks.
Yeah.
And,
and now they have apps where you can upload your face and you can change things
about your face.
And it's just,
we're,
we're all becoming more and more insecure I think with social media.
Um,
and,
and yeah,
it's part of this world where we,
where nothing is real.
Well,
that's the other part of it.
There's a lot of these pictures aren't real.
No.
People are doctoring their photos to make themselves look different than they
actually do.
Look,
and then I know someone walks into the studio and you're like,
wait,
that's not the,
that's not what I thought that person was going to look like.
This a woman who is friends with my wife,
her neighbor is a model and she takes all of her photos with no makeup on and
then they put the makeup on her.
Oh my God,
I didn't know they could do that.
Yeah.
That's how they do it.
They do it all through Photoshop,
so she,
Jamie,
can you do that for [inaudible] in this video?
You can do whatever.
You can turn you into an Avatar.
Do you got anything?
But it's kind of crazy that they,
they take photos with no makeup and then add the eye shadow and all this wild
wheat.
Nothing's real.
Nothing is real anymore.
We kind of just,
what we're,
I think we're,
I mean,
I don't want to go down this road in this conversation,
but I think we're preparing ourselves for a time where nothing Israel,
I think you're preparing ourselves for a time where we live inside some sort of
a simulation.
Yeah.
And I think on,
it's interesting because celebrities like yourself have to really think about
how your image is used after you're gone as well now.
Like something that you didn't have to think about.
So,
um,
there was a commercial,
Audrey Hepburn in Britain and,
um,
she's,
it's,
it's a galaxy chocolate commercial and she's there and it looks like she's
eating a chocolate bar.
And so the ways that they can manipulate images and,
um,
and I think for the first time a lot of celebrities need to really think
carefully about whether they're okay with their images being used in certain
kinds of ways after their death.
Like,
who owns your image?
It's just like when you look at medical history in the past,
you don't own your body.
And so a lot of these surgeons get hold of these bodies to dissect and they're
digging them up from,
from graveyards.
I,
there were body snatchers,
they called themselves resurrection men.
And they would go into these cemeteries and they would dig up these bodies and
they would oftentimes strip the body naked because it was,
it was illegal to steal possessions from the corpse but not the body itself.
Cause there was no,
there was no concept of the body being sort of property.
So they would throw the clothes back into the grave and,
and they were really clever and the ways they did it,
they usually sent a woman in the daytime to,
to masquerade as a mourner and she would kind of go through the graveyard and
she would see where the fresh graves were.
Because of course you'd want the body to be as fresh as possible.
And then at nighttime they would go in there and they would dig up these bodies
and they could take as many as 12 bodies in a night.
It was like hard labor and it was very lucrative.
Um,
because the only legal bodies to dissect in Britain,
um,
in the early 19th century war bodies have executed criminals of people who had
murdered other people.
So specifically murders
went to the like to say goodbye to your Nana and drop some flowers on a grave
and there's just a big hole in the ground.
Well,
they would cover it up,
but you do get these stories of people finding out that a body.
So for instance,
I think it was in 1785 on this person,
goes to this graveyard and discovers that a body is missing,
that a body has been snatched and everybody in the village goes his graveyard
and digs up their relatives and drags these coffins back to their home until
they could make the cemetery safer,
which is insane because people were really feared this.
And um,
so yesterday on Twitter I put up a picture of something called the cemetery
gone.
So they had these devices that they would put at the foot of the grave and it
had like a trip wire.
And so you can set up the gun to shoot anybody you would god.
And there's,
there's actually really awful story of a grieving father who he there,
this was set up at the grave and he accidentally trips it and he gets shot.
So,
you know,
it wasn't,
it wasn't exactly a safe way to protect the bodies,
but they also have watchman look,
there it is.
That's what you were yesterday.
Your Twitter feed.
That's Twitter.
Yeah.
Everybody went nuts on that yesterday.
Military gun,
19th centuries to protect against quality standards.
That is so crazy.
It's a musket.
Yeah,
it was hardcore.
I mean,
you'd have to be quite wealthy as well to,
to set something like that up at the,
at the foot of your relatives grave.
They also used coffin collars.
So that was sort of like an iron.
Um,
well it was,
it was a collar and they would nail it to the bottom of the coffin,
so that way.
So what,
what a body snatcher would typically do,
just open the foot of the grave.
You wouldn't dig up the whole grave.
He'd Smash Open the lid and he'd have instruments to kind of drag the body out.
Well,
if the corpses nailed to the bottom of the coffin,
you're going to have a lot of trouble dragging that body out.
So people,
you know,
they did all kinds of things.
They put these cages over the,
over the graves to protect them.
So people,
the Internet,
God bless it will say to protect against vampire or to keep vampires from coming
out.
It had nothing to do with that or zombies.
It was to prevent body snatchers from getting ahold of those corpses.
But you know those bodies.
Yeah,
there they are.
Mort safes,
they were called God and you'll see them a lot in Britain.
Um,
and there they were,
people were very paranoid about this.
I mean,
you can find a lot of examples of this and bodies were stolen a lot and thank
God they were on some level,
right?
Because think about how much we learned from these bodies.
Bodies were needed to be dissected to teach medical students.
And,
um,
one of the scenes in the book,
I talk about the dead house,
they called it the dead house and everybody had a different experience in the
dead house.
There's probably people listening who've,
who've been in a dissection room and you have a really vivid memory of that.
It's probably bright and white and clinical.
Well,
these places,
the bodies would have been bloated and partly decomposed.
Uh,
dissecting bodies was dangerous because you could cut yourself and you can
infect yourself with bacteria.
They weren't wearing gloves.
Um,
and so you get,
uh,
examples of people cutting themselves and dying within 40 hours.
So going into Madison was dangerous.
And there's a story in this book about a guy who goes into the,
the dad house for the first time and he freaks out and he sees all these like
mice and rats and things like that,
eating the bodies.
And so he jumps out the window and he,
and he runs off,
but later he becomes a cost into it.
As we all become accustomed to horrible things at some point.
And he actually starts taking pieces of the corpse and throwing it to the poor
little starving creatures that are in the dead house.
And so he's kind of like,
you know,
that,
that horror that we all experienced possibly when we,
when we're confronted with death to accepting it as you have to as a medical
student if you want to go on.
Um,
so the dead houses is particularly,
it would have smelled,
um,
dissection would've,
would've been a winter sport because the body's wouldn't decompose this quickly.
You course wouldn't want to be dissecting in the heat of the summer.
Um,
and
yeah,
they would,
they would tend to teach students in the winter.
So it was cold winter jackets.
Yeah,
they will,
they would have probably cause while they had a fireplace at the end of the room
as well and make a really stuffy and smelly and you couldn't really predict what
a person had died from as well.
So remember,
people are dying from things like smallpox,
which is awful.
Um,
and this is before bass vaccinations.
This is certainly before antibiotics.
And so a lot of doctors or medical students die as a result of going into the
profession.
Oh Wow.
So there are they getting it from these courses.
People that die,
they can get bacterial infections certainly.
And just being with patients.
If a patient comes in and smallpox and smallpox,
a lot of people,
I don't know if I,
did I send you a picture of smallpox,
Jamie.
Um,
a lot of people think,
oh,
it's,
it's like chicken pox.
It's not like chicken pox.
It's,
it's a really awful disease.
Um,
and it's the only disease that we have eradicated ever in human history.
Yeah.
Um,
which is incredible.
So it's,
it's one of those ones.
Yeah.
There,
it's unbelievably bad.
It makes me itch.
When I looked at it,
horrific.
Um,
very disfigured
with it.
It's just,
and it was so common.
It was very common.
It was,
it was very feared as well because it was so disfiguring.
And so if you were,
for instance,
a wealthy woman and you got smallpox and you were scarred,
your family might worry that they couldn't marry you off.
So,
you know,
it was one of those diseases that left its mark on you,
literally.
Um,
and,
and it also had a high mortality rate as well,
but it wasn't like chicken pox.
No,
there's my PSA.
It's not like chicken pox.
Well,
it's,
uh,
you know,
it's one of those things that we're so thankful that people have figured out how
to get rid of something.
Yeah.
And,
and,
um,
and smallpox vaccine was invented in the 18th century.
Most people don't know it's,
it's that old,
um,
doctor.
Yeah.
Edward Jenner invented it.
And actually the biggest anti-vaxxer movement or a protest happened in the 19th
century.
100,000 people turned out to March and Britain against Jenner,
people thought that,
um,
their children return into cows because he used cow pox,
the virus,
cow pox to bestow immunity onto people.
And so there was this huge fear that,
um,
you know,
it was dirty to kind of insert this animal virus into people.
And so there was this big protest,
100,000 people to protest the fact that six parents had been jailed for not
vaccinating their children.
And so the stories is much older than we think.
And the fears that we have about vaccines are not that dissimilar to what people
worried about in the past as well.
But gender is in an incredible figure.
That is incredible when you stop and think about the fact that this is still
going on today with the Internet.
Yeah.
All the mean.
You can find out.
I mean I had doctor Peter Hotez on recently to talk about vaccines and the
misconceptions that people have and he explained that they have isolated a bunch
of different environmental factors,
the end genes that contribute to autism,
but that all takes place in the womb.
Right.
But people don't want to hear that.
No,
I mean it,
and that is the danger of the way information is now spread.
Of course,
echo chambers.
It's confirmation bias is the real danger that people get around wasn't,
it was actually harder to get that message out.
But I'm a lot of,
uh,
you know,
you get famous sort of,
um,
cartoons of,
of people sort of turning into cows to the cartoon is my new husband is
cartoonists.
And so it's like this way of this powerful way of kind of conveying images and
fears and stuff.
And um,
so yeah,
people,
people had that fear of vaccines for a long time,
but Edward Jenner coming up with his vaccine undoubtedly saved millions of
people's lives.
It's so amazing that,
that the problem is still around today.
We even with all the information that we have available.
Yeah.
I think,
you know,
there was,
um,
a Fox News,
uh,
a newscaster who recently said that he doesn't wash his hands because he can't
see germs.
I don't know who it was.
Hopefully was joking actually wash those hands.
I hope so.
So people were sending that to me because again,
like lister and,
um,
and I always tell people,
you know,
it is that idea of what you can't see.
It's hard to convince people.
And with lister,
you know,
if you think about it,
here's this young guy and he's coming along and he's saying there are these
invisible little creatures and they're killing your patients and trust me,
I have this really weird instrument called the microscope and I can see them.
And it was a leap of faith.
He was also accusing the older surgeons of inadvertently killing their patients
because if they weren't washing their hands,
they were leading to higher mortality rates.
So they probably fall against it as well.
Yeah.
So there was,
there was huge push back.
So what lister ultimately does is he turns to the younger generation and he
changes their minds.
And so it's a slow burn.
It's not like,
you know,
the movie moment unfortunately,
where it just happens all at once and it takes quite a long time.
Um,
and it's,
it's weird that it takes so long because if you think about him coming in 1876
to America,
it's after the civil war,
people were dying,
soldiers were dying of high infection rates.
They were packing wounds with mud.
I mean,
it couldn't get worse than that.
Right.
And so people were dying of all the,
all of these kinds of infections.
He comes to Philadelphia to convince the medical community.
And Speaker after speaker just denounce his,
him on the first day and then he gets up and he,
he does his demonstrations and he starts to slowly change people's minds.
But it takes a long time.
The,
the cover of the,
um,
of the American book is,
the American version I should say is,
I'm a famous painting by people can see that by Samuel Gross.
It's called the gross clinic.
I'm the guy in the middle.
It is gross as well,
but the guy in the middle of Samuel Gross,
and he's so didn't believe in lister that he would walk into the room and he'd
slam the door and he'd say,
there,
Mister Lister's germs can't get in anymore.
And you can see in this that he stick,
he's wearing his street clothes,
he's sticking his dirty fingers into this wound.
Um,
and there's a woman in the background and she's covering her face and she's the
mother of the patient and she's wearing black because she expects her son to
die.
So,
so this is the US cover and for the UK cover,
I think I sent that to you Jamie.
Um,
it's a,
I sent you a picture of both covers side by side.
It's another painting by Eakins and it was done within 10 years and it's called
the Agnew clinic.
And it's totally different because the doctors are wearing white.
There's a sense that they understand germs,
there's a sense of antisepsis been used there.
So that kind of before and after shot in such a short period that listers able
to change the world.
What made you choose a different covers for the UK and the US version?
Well,
so that's actually,
writers don't,
Oh there you go.
So you can see.
So penguin published it in the UK,
so they've stylized the original painting,
but you kind of get a sense of what it would've looked like on any,
and actually you have women appearing in the operating theater professionally as
nurses.
So this is after the Florence Nightingale Revolution as well.
So it still looks different to the way we operate.
But you can definitely see a difference between those two paintings.
Can you refresh my memory and the Florence Nightingale Revolution.
So Florence,
Florence Nightingale is in this book a little bit.
People always wonder why I didn't speak about her is much.
But actually she didn't believe in germs at first.
She thought lister was quite a hysterical with his idea of germs,
but she was working towards sanitation in hospitals.
So they're working towards the same goal but just with different slightly
different tactics.
So she revolutionizes nursing,
um,
to make it a more respectable profession.
Before then nurses,
you wouldn't want your daughter becoming a nurse if you were from a well
respected family because it was,
she would be privy to the male body.
So you wouldn't want her interacting with male patients.
So really kind of lowly,
um,
poorer women went into nursing.
Um,
and it wasn't really a respected profession until Florence Nightingale comes
along and there's this sort of revolution.
So the revolution is not just about the profession though,
but it's about the sanitation reforms that she brings about in the hospitals.
So you see that on the cover as well.
But there's,
there's also another guy,
I'm sure there's like,
I can,
I always like sorta predict comments.
I shouldn't think about,
you know,
what people are going to say,
but people tend to get mad.
I'm like,
when I give lectures,
because I don't talk about this guy,
there's,
there's groupies out there,
um,
that love this physician named Semmelweis.
And I do talk about them in the book a little bit.
So Semmelweiss was this,
I call them groupies,
Semmelweiss groupies because every time I give a talk,
there's always one person who asked this question and I have to spell it myself.
And I'm like,
ah,
here it is.
And they say,
why I think you'll find you haven't talked about Semmelweiss Semmelweiss,
uh,
was,
was practicing in Austria and he was putting this idea to gather that if you
wash your hands and you go onto the hospital wards,
infection rates went down.
Um,
and they call,
he was ridiculed heavily.
They call them the hand washer and he ends up being put in an insane asylum and
it's this really kind of sad,
weird death that he has.
And,
um,
and he's really sort of,
persecuted for these ideas of hand washing and,
and infection rates.
He's doing it a little bit before lister comes onto the scene listers,
not aware of some of vices work,
but equally,
I always tell people that some of vice doesn't really do it first if we're,
if we're going to play that game.
Because again,
there's a difference between the basic sanitation and then understanding why
you're implementing it.
So until you understand that germs exist,
it doesn't make sense.
You can't really convince people.
And that's,
lister comes in,
he takes lead pastors germ theory,
and he's able to convince people,
I'm in the medical community that germs exist.
So until we understand,
you know,
again,
why wash your hands if they're just going to get dirty?
That's amazing.
So I get why did you have two different covers?
Oh,
yes.
Um,
so the,
the publisher just picks whatever covers they want basically on.
So my us publisher had come up with this.
My UK publisher came up with a cover.
I didn't like that much.
And so I said,
well,
why don't we use the second Eakins paintings so that they're,
um,
in conversation with one another.
So I like that they kind of compliment one another.
I like the font better.
I know,
I love this Victorian Font and the image of that guy wearing street clothes is
just more,
it's so evocative.
I,
you know,
it's just this book,
this cover actually,
so it's been translated,
I think it's about 15 languages now.
So most of them kind of take this,
this image.
I was wondering if you knew what this might be.
This is,
so it's a circular metal metal contraption,
um,
with teeth on the inside for people who are just listening.
So this is called the Geogen penis.
This is an,
a Victorian anti masturbation device.
So yay.
There's the real one.
This is,
this is a prop that I use for under the knife.
Um,
that's the real ones.
So what would happen is if the person got an erection,
it would clamp down and obviously kill the erection pretty quickly.
Yeah,
that's one we made for the show.
Yeah.
It's basically,
it's similar.
If you see like the one on the screen,
it has a spring device.
So these,
they were trying,
why were they trying to get people to stop?
So the Victorians were obsessed with,
with masturbation.
And there's probably a lot of people out there who know that Kellogg's
cornflakes came out of this sort of obsession with masturbation story.
We heard it from Dr Chris Ryan.
Oh,
it's so funny.
Well,
it's funny.
In a Haha kind of horrifying way.
Um,
Kellogg was,
was obsessed with,
with masturbation.
He thought that a lot of his patients were suffering from all kinds of mental
ailments and physical ailments because they were masturbating too much.
And he thought that a diet bland in a bland,
in high in fiber would kind of kill the fire in the belly.
And so he invented what became Kellogg's cornflakes.
But his brother was the one who commercialized and his brothers like,
we should add sugar.
And Dr. Kelly was like,
no,
people,
we masturbating all the time.
We can't add sugar,
you know?
And they had this split and Kellogg's corn flakes.
It became the commercial version with the delicious sugar added in.
So that was the brother's idea.
It was the brother's idea to add the sugar and make it sort of delicious.
Oh yeah.
That's,
that was a um,
uh,
illustrated by my husband.
We do all kinds of,
yeah.
For you too.
So that's not an original.
No,
no.
Heard your son and heir dirty little self abuser.
Stop All contemptible.
Is this an actual text from,
uh,
you know,
I don't know.
I,
I doubt it.
A cock lane in London though.
Stop All contemptible.
Oh Nan in Islam,
what is own an ism?
Masturbating and [inaudible].
Have you ever heard that
with the infallible and modestly priced juke him penis.
So was that a common thing during the Victorian era?
So yeah,
you get the idea that masturbating is bad for your health goes to the 18th
century.
We kind of tend to think about it is a Victorian obsession cause it,
it becomes more and more accepted idea in medical terms but that it's bad for
you and you get these like sort of drawings of men like languishing on the
couch.
Cause like masturbated too much or whatever is out there right now that can
relate.
Yeah.
Energy,
you know,
they just need the chicken penis and,
and also there's another one I sent you Jamie.
I think that this sort of like,
it looks like a flacid penis.
It's really high.
Yeah.
They came in all shapes and sizes and yeah,
like now it would probably just be,
yeah,
they're just supposed to pee out of that.
Yeah,
maybe you cuss it actually the end of it,
like you have to just,
there is,
there are examples
for the bottom was the hook that seems super uncomfortable.
Where is that thing sits in between your legs.
So it must be like a hook where you could strap it in and drop it in
a tie.
Steel Cup.
I don't know who's coming on the show afterwards,
but they got a lot of,
the good news is Ron is a hilarious comedian,
so
I might have to Redo the entire show just with Ron and his take on all this
stuff.
Yeah,
just show the,
I'll just leave these objects behind the cup too.
A little.
It's so gross.
It's gross and the fact you're the pee out of those,
a spaghetti strainer at the end of it,
I knew,
I thought,
you know what?
I was going on the show.
I'm like,
what can I bring Joe Rogan that's going to stimulate the conversation and the
anti masturbation device,
it's a crowd pleaser with men.
It's always an issue of fascination.
They thought that it was causing all these ailments.
They thought it was causing all these different problems and Graham crackers as
well come out of that.
So Reverend Graham was also obsessed with masturbation,
just like Kellogg.
And so he created this sort of dry,
tasteless.
So everybody crumbling them into their little,
did he know that smores and makes it pretty fucking awesome.
Add marshmallows [inaudible] right.
So we're just like,
I don't know if it works.
If people feel like that that's helping them with their masturbation problems,
but hey,
leave a comment.
Which is crazy that people didn't,
most people have no idea that that was the origin of this stuff.
That's what's so funny.
You know,
there's,
there's so many like Listerine,
Graham crackers,
Kellogg corn flakes,
all this kind of stuff that that has sort of a medical background or a medical
background in,
um,
the term hysterical that hysterical was related to women.
Yeah.
The idea that the womb wanders like,
so people thought that the,
that the female wound was like an animal in and of itself,
which I know,
you know,
um,
and it would move around the body and so they would even do things like they
would smoke it back into place,
they'd put like smoke.
They would put like incense and all kinds of things to kind of like get it,
like coax it back into place.
I can't even imagine that people are going to start following me after this
based off of these,
these weird stories come to my platform.
I have tons of different stories like this,
but there was,
um,
there was a time where women would go to the doctor to get stimulated as well.
Right.
Is that true?
Or is it,
so this is like a little bit out of my expertise.
I think that's been proven to be false.
Actually on,
but,
but there was,
I believe,
and I could be wrong on this,
that there was a Victorian idea that a woman had to orgasm in order to become
pregnant.
So that was,
that was an important part of it.
I wasn't just a Victorian thing.
I'm pretty sure they taught me that in high school.
What are you closes?
They're like,
if you want to get a woman pregnant,
made sure she harkness ideas as part of the male orgasming inside the woman was
what led to her having an orgasm,
which would lead to her getting pregnant.
That is weird.
Well there was,
there was,
I think it was like a sign of completely [inaudible].
I was probably 15 at the time.
Well there you go.
But there was,
there was someone on,
I think it was like a senator or Congress.
I live in the UK now,
so I'm not as up to date with,
with all the crazy stuff going on over here.
Um,
but I think there was like a senator who said this again,
this idea that a woman had to like orgasm it meeting undermining the idea that
you couldn't be great unless you had an orgasm,
which was a Victorian.
Yeah,
I think that was really recently.
I think it was like in the last year.
I hate to say like how should this be like in the background popping up and like
I could have like a sign that says 18th century or 19th.
So you know,
like where did that idea come from originally?
And that's,
I do have this weird,
weird,
vague memory that that was the way that you were taught.
It's too weird.
I don't remember.
It's too vague.
It does sound too weird.
Like I now I picture you went to like a really big Torian school and went to a
place called Newton,
south suburb of Boston.
Really Nice.
Cool.
Nothing wrong with it other than other than that,
your sex Ed,
I'm not sure if that was,
and did they pass out the Jig and penis as well after?
They did smack are,
but why were people so with that while they have soap sells self pleasuring.
Yeah.
And I think that again,
you know,
you look at that sort of buttoned up Victorian mentality like dresses over the
legs of pianos and chairs and stuff like that.
I don't know about that.
I think they did it because it had been provocative.
It might be more bullshit that I remember,
but I really do remember something.
I like the fact check this before I just did.
It's Horse Shit,
right?
It says it's not real.
Oh,
okay.
You know what?
I remember where I heard it from,
I heard it from Terence Mckenna.
It was one of the things he talked about during one of his,
uh,
his speeches there.
That's right.
We did.
We did fact check that.
I mean,
we like to think that,
that the past is really different from us,
which it is in some ways,
but you know,
again,
like we still share some similar fears and the masturbation thing.
Actually,
the last thing I want to show you that I brought is this.
So this is,
this is a urine wheel that would date to the medieval period.
And so the idea was that the doctor could diagnose you according to the color of
your urine.
Spoiler alert if your urine is black,
you're probably in big trouble.
Just,
yeah,
they didn't
look at the color.
They tasted the urine as well.
Areas so,
so and,
and they could diagnose diabetes because someone with diabetes,
their urine tastes sweet.
So they were actually diagnosing diabetes.
Yeah,
there you go.
That's the one we based it off yet.
But my favorite part of the urine in the medieval period and doctors with your,
they some,
some practitioners would take the urine and put it into a divination,
a bowl and they could tell your future and I think they should bring that back,
you know,
at the end of your checkout,
not to be covered by insurance,
but you know,
out of pocket,
totally dehydrated and there's blood,
do the divination ball.
You don't have to do that.
Well it's weird that image,
the whole circle,
the center circle,
like a guy is the doctor holding the flask or the doctor.
Yep.
That would be the doctor holding the flask and actually it's like a wine taster.
Again,
a youtube video on this,
which is why I have this stupid prop.
And um,
we cut through images in that image of the doctor holding the flask was sort of
the predominant image of a physician up into a certain period.
Now it's sort of like the stethoscope is the,
is the object now that we associate with doctors but for a year and flask used
to be it
and the,
and the plague mask,
but they used to call him piss profits because they tell your fortune using your
urine.
So we should,
I think that is something we should bring back.
I think you have the power to bring that back.
Well you know what,
if there's Tarot card readers went up his profits.
Yeah,
piss profits are basing it on something
that divination.
But I know there's so many images of the doctor holding the flask and you know,
obviously like the color of your urine could be an indicator of health.
It still is today.
And look at the guy,
he's like,
what do you think?
Dark?
He looks like he's very,
very worried.
Yeah.
That's profits in La.
Most police during open up this door right now.
Look at them.
The bandaid around the guy's head.
Yeah.
Like he's hurting.
You guys got a head injury and the doctors check in this next image.
What's going on there?
I think he's pulling a tooth.
You know Christ the barbers when they pulled teeth that sometimes they would
have a drum in the shop and it would get louder as they got closer to point the
teeth,
which would make me more anxious.
And the barber shop was,
was a male domain because you'd also get advice on sexual diseases.
Cause of course,
so this is a fake nose.
So everybody's sort of lost their noses.
They lose loser.
No.
Okay.
So something you probably don't,
you probably don't know about syphilis.
I don't know if we have that image of,
of syphilis that I sent poor Jamie.
I told him your bookie manager,
Matt stags,
I said send these images to Jamie and don't tell them any contacts.
You know,
what the hell is this podcast be on
today?
Lost her nose is so syphilis attack sort of the soft tissue and the image that I
sent through,
which we'll show in a minute on the guy has um,
holds in his scalp as well.
That's a photograph that is a photograph in the 19th century.
So he actually,
he held onto his nose though,
so you could just cover that with a hat.
But it was,
it was incredibly painful and you,
Al Capone had syphilis and so you lost your mind.
It attacked the soft tissues,
technical brain.
It was really,
so people today,
you know,
I'll show these images on my Instagram or Twitter and people be like,
wow,
I didn't know syphilis was so bad.
It's like people die from it all the time.
Is also responsible for powdered wigs.
No,
no.
Yeah.
You got something,
I forget.
Some noble person got syphilis and started wearing a wig and when they started
wearing wigs,
other people started emulating them because they were the celebrities of the
kingdom.
I feel like this is a drunk history is real.
It's legitimate.
And the more wealthy you were like,
cause he's syphilis makes your hair fall out as well,
your teeth fall out.
And so the more wealthy you were,
the bigger and taller your wig would be.
That is where the term big wigs comes from.
That's interesting.
I mean I knew that in the 18th century that the wigs were getting bigger as the
fashions.
In fact,
um,
uh,
my husband illustrated book called the gin link is that it's sort of like an
18th century newspaper.
And as the newspaper on moves on,
the women would have to sit at the bottom of the carriage because their wigs
were so high in some cases.
But the women had syphilis.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Because it would be passed on or so that's probably why they had wigs as well.
Yeah.
And I'm with syphilis,
you know,
your nose fell off and it was so prevalent in the 19th century that they had no
nose clubs.
So people would get together.
Yeah.
And they would,
in London they would share the fact that,
you know,
we,
yeah,
we lost her nose.
We have simply couldn't smell anything either.
No,
I mean it was awful.
And actually one of the ways that they treated syphilis was through mercury,
which is very cool.
And so when you talk about the loss,
those club writers,
and I don't know if that's the no,
no,
it was closed.
Yeah,
they might,
they might have STDs though.
Says yeah,
I'll just stand there with top out's and underwear.
Um,
pull up the thing though about big wigs.
Oh,
so it can,
uh,
oh,
do you see,
do you see that one right up there?
Oh,
oh yeah,
that's fine.
If you go up,
wait up Jamie and goats one.
Yes.
So that man didn't lose his notes as syphilis,
but that's an early form of a rhinoplasty that they,
that dates back to the renaissance and you'd have to stay in that position for
weeks.
While that grafted,
um,
I believe this man was,
had a Sukkot of is for people just listing,
there's a slice off of his arm that's connected to his nose and they have taped
and strapped his arm to hit the top of his head.
So he's stay in this position while his,
the chunk of his arm grows into his face and then they're going to cut it and
remove it.
When it develops its own blood supply.
It's like,
it's like the nick,
if people have watched that show nick on,
they have a scene with this.
So yeah,
it was so uncomfortable on the better off of no nos.
Yeah,
you might be better off and mercury of course you would lose your teeth and it
just really awful kinds of things they did was took your work.
And how long did that last for the mercury thing?
Ah,
all the way into the 19th century.
And so there's a phrase for a bunch of people died when they go,
hey guys,
this paper you're still copying.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Okay.
Syphilis hidden between powder whey,
syphilis epidemic and 15 hundreds year of left people with patchy hair loss.
Um,
gold go to the actual,
um,
the,
who is it?
What,
what?
Yeah.
So these nobleman,
they're all gross,
disgusting people with STDs.
But what is the name of the guy?
Oh,
hold on.
Don't scroll.
Go back up here.
Yeah.
Okay.
There it is.
Oh,
Louis the Fort Louis the 14th only 17 his mom started thinking worth baldest
might hurt his reputation.
Louie hired 48 wig makers to save as image five years later,
King.
So,
but if you scroll down,
they didn't likely had syphilis boltman likelihood syphilis.
So this is what started it all out.
No,
it's interesting.
Yeah.
That's hideous to like.
Well there was some modern sensibilities like that just looks so bizarre.
Well,
Natalie,
yeah,
I mean everything's gross,
right?
No one's washing themselves.
They don't know what germs are.
Still forced to watch a Hollywood movie.
They're like,
oh,
it'd be so beautiful delivering the pet now.
We're such assholes with that is,
it drives me crazy when people want to pretend romanticize that it was so
lovely.
There are terrible things about life today.
There absolutely are.
But this is the best time to be alive ever by far.
Yeah.
People say on,
is this the best time medically?
And it's like,
well,
hopefully that's always true.
Right.
You hopefully tomorrow is.
That is better than,
you know,
hopefully we're,
we're advancing and learning more and everything.
I mean,
I think that,
you know,
we shouldn't look at a science and medicine is totally linear like that.
We're progressing towards something but that,
you know,
obviously we're,
we're learning from what doesn't work and that's why I said failure is a huge
part of what I love to talk about and on Youtube and stuff because we just don't
talk about it enough in life and science and medicine and all the things that
fail and um,
help us get to where we are today.
Well Lindsay,
thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for writing this awesome book and thank you for your amazing Twitter
feed.
I'm,
I've been spending many,
many,
many moments.
Freaking the fuck out.
Reading your stuff.
Washing manages a,
I'm really happy you could come down here and share all this stuff with us.
Thank you so much for your dad.
Show.
Tell people how to get ahold of you on Instagram,
how they can check out your feed.
Okay,
mom.
I'm Dr. Lindsey Fitzharris on Instagram and Dr. Lindsay fits on on Twitter and
under the knife on Youtube,
and the book is the butchering art and get it on Amazon.
I'd really love it if you bought it.
They're going to buy it.
I guarantee you your Hogan stepped by it.
It's really,
it's really good.
And I freaked you out.
Thank you so much,
Lindsey.
Bye everybody.
Hmm?